all right people this
is the reuben report direct message for
october 21st
2020 i am dave rubin and we
are less than two weeks away
from the day that ghouls and goblins
will run amok in the streets that's
right people
election day is only 13 days away
there's also halloween
but i'm pretty sure they outlawed that
so we're gonna stick with election day
uh all right the craziness is being
ramped up so we're gonna cover
uh three stories for you today
and actually two of them have nothing
really to do with the presidential
election in and of itself
i thought that would escape us a little
bit they sort of ancillarily do
but not directly about the election and
one of them is just about a bananas
person
who is for some reason a public person
too
uh so the three stories we're gonna
knock out today uh the department of
justice has announced a lawsuit against
google basically an anti-trust lawsuit
and this is all about breaking up their
monopoly there's a lot to discuss here
philosophically depending on where you
fall and what level
of government involvement you want and
do you think the government has any
right to break up a monopoly most on the
purely libertarian side would say no
some on the sort of more classical
liberal side would say okay maybe you
don't want government regulators but you
might want to break them up because you
do want to be wary about some power
on the conservative side now i see a lot
of people saying absolutely break them
up and regulate them and do whatever you
got to do because if we don't this is
our last chance to stop them
that's generally not a conservative
position usually
it's the democrats it's the lefties who
want more government involvement and are
sort of more anti-anti-business
but in a certain level at this point
it's hard to figure out
if google is the government or not or if
they're at least more powerful than the
government so we'll talk
about all of those issues and more then
there was a
fantastic video that went viral
yesterday
by a conservative mp in the uk by the
name of kemi
badanak who happens to be a black woman
and she basically lashes out
on critical race theory so we're going
to show you the video
and talk a little bit about what she
said and and the reason i wanted to show
it was
because you know most of the stuff that
i do here is from an american
perspective but these terrible ideas
of critical race theory of identity
politics
these collectivist ideas that have been
the wrong ideas
for millennia from the beginning of time
basically the things that have
caused you know tribes to kill other
tribes because they looked a little
different and they were obsessed with
skin color and ethnicity and everything
else
these bad ideas are everywhere right
it's not just an american phenomenon we
know it's happening
in every well it's happening in every
country but it's happening in every
western country to some degree where
people are told
to be guilty about their skin color or
where they're from
or what their religion is or the rest of
it we know it's happening in canada it's
happening in australia it's happening in
the uk it's happening in ireland i mean
it's
australia it's happening absolutely
everywhere so it's always good to see
when a politician actually stands up for
the truth
and fights it i'm sure the mob is going
to come for her but we're going to show
you that video and talk about that
and then finally you remember this guy
keith
olbermann i remember keith olbermann
because when i was
in college i wanted to be a broadcaster
i actually wanted to go
to syracuse university which was sort of
the broadcasting capital of the world
that's where you went i'm pretty sure
marv albert went there and bob costas
went there
and it was like that's where if you
wanted to be a broadcaster of any kind
not just a sports broadcaster
that's where you'd want to go i ended up
going to suny binghamton which is a
state school in new york
which is only about 40 minutes away and
i visited syracuse a couple times and
really did want to go there
but i wanted to be a sports center
anchor that's not exactly what i'm doing
these days but i guess i'm ballparking
sort of doing something anchoring
something right
but keith olbermann was a great anchor
on sportscenter
uh those of you of a certain age will
remember him with dan patrick on the big
show
and they were funny and irreverent and
interesting and everything else
well that was already about 20 some odd
years ago
about 23 24 years ago which seems like a
lifetime ago and then
over the course of the last 23 or so
years
he became sort of just like a
progressive hysterical
nut bag that would be what i would put
under his chiron
a progressive hysterical nut bag who's
had a show a couple shows i think on
msnbc
and then he had a show on current tv and
then he had a show on the gq network
whatever that is
all his shows fail and he just screams
like a complete lunatic but he had a
video yesterday that was so
ridiculously over the top calling for
the death penalty
for donald trump that i just wanted to
show it not to
not even really to mock the guy but i
want to show you just sort of some of
the tricks
that the people who are in this business
the business of talking to the camera
some of the tricks that they use to
outrage you and confuse you and
everything else
and he as a sort of just like nothing
faux angry pretend newsman i think he's
like the epitome
of what's wrong with all this stuff i
don't even know that anyone's really
watching i think he has a show on
youtube now i don't know that anyone's
really watching it
so in a weird way i'm drawing attention
to it by showing it but trust me people
grant me a little leash here grant me a
little leash
and uh i think you'll see why i wanted
to do it
okay so let's start with this department
of justice lawsuit against google
the house and senate as of yesterday
they have brought a lawsuit against
google this is an anti-trust
lawsuit which is basically saying that
it's using
it google is using its power to preserve
its monopoly
and there's a couple interesting numbers
i can throw out you throw at you here
right now google over the last couple
years controls nearly 90 percent
of all general search queries in the
united states
and 95 of mobile search queries so
let's put aside the break up and
regulate stuff for just a second let's
just talk about the information side of
it because i think that
that's probably the most important thing
and also let's not forget you're
most likely watching this on youtube and
if you are watching this on youtube
youtube is owned by google and google
can decide at any moment which videos
they want to get out
and which videos they don't so it's sort
of
annoying for me to have to talk about
like the inner machinations of what's
going on
on google and youtube but like we have a
for the reuben report channel
we have a you know like a creator's
panel where we have all of the tools
they can show us what's happening with
our channel and what monetized and what
didn't and how many people are watching
and where they're from and how long they
watch for
and all of these things and then they
also show us oh this video
more of your subscribers saw it or this
video it was recommended more or a
series of these things but in essence
when they're showing us those things
um what they're saying to us is we have
a certain set of rules this algorithm
that nobody can really define nor know
about
and i'm not going to sit here and
pretend i'm an expert in the algorithm
at this point i don't think there's any
expert in the algorithm i don't i don't
know if there's one person
on earth truly at this point who could
honestly with a straight face tell you
that they really
understand the google algorithm not
let's not forget this thing
was built by engineers over the course
now of
multiple decades and many of them and
they come and go and it's like we've
sort of lost control of the algorithm
if you if you want a simpler version of
that i would say watch the movie i robot
with um with will smith about how you
lose control of these things
um but in essence they can say oh
the video that you put out yesterday
ruben report this one more of your
subscribers watched it
now does that mean it's because they
sent it to more of our subscribers or
more of our subscribers were interested
in it we don't know
sometimes they'll say it was watched
more when it was recommended more well
it's
okay do you mean you the algorithm
recommended it more
did people recommend it more to their
friends so
that's very similar to what's going on
with the search situation
if you are favored by google search and
it does seem that you can become favored
either by money or political favors or
probably a series of other things
well then if you search someone's name
and someone wants good
things to come out about them then
you'll get pages of good things
if they don't like you or let's say
you're not woke perhaps because we do
know that wokeness has infected this
entire
system then they're going to show bad
things a simple way to do this
put joe biden in the search bar and see
what comes out see if it's generally
positive or negative
and then put donald trump in the search
bar and see if it's positive or negative
so
so this is where now to bring it to the
to the antitrust part the break up the
companies the monopoly part the regulate
part this is where it gets really tricky
so
i'll try to do this as as cleanly as i
possibly can
the purely libertarian side of me and
i'm not a pure libertarian
the purely libertarian side of me this
is where say the the iron ran people so
like a guy like euron brook
who i've had on the show many times who
i love and think is a great thinker
this is where joe jorgensen the
libertarian candidate for president who
had on a few weeks ago this is this is
what their position would be
the government has absolutely no right
to do anything here google is a private
company they can do whatever they
want and and only competition can
can solve these problems and any time
the government gets involved in anything
it makes the problems worth
worse i think that that is a legit
position to hold i i don't think that is
a dishonest position i think it's
probably the most
honest position and it's probably the
sort of most cleanly
intellectual position you can hold on
this the government the government
getting involved in these things
rarely makes it better um i think it was
ronald reagan who said there's no
problem
that the government can't create and
then make worse that's a loose quote
there
uh or there's no problem that the
government hasn't created that they
can't make worse
and i think that's the general idea like
the idea that government regulators if
you're for
regulating google think what you're
saying like it kind of sounds right well
google has too much power over us we
know that they're woke we know that they
don't like conservatives or
right-leaning people like the i've met
people i've been to youtube's offices
i've met a lot of these people okay
they're not
fans of let's say what i'm doing here or
what you guys are probably doing
so i'm i'm not defending that but the
idea that we're going to send a
government regulator try to picture
the guy who has the job as the
government regulator like this dork in
his pleated pants and
you know and he shows up at google hi
there i'm here to look at the
uh the algorithm okay it's like this is
not going to solve anything right if
if that government regulator knew how to
do anything he wouldn't be working for
the government
he would be working for google in the
first place right or he'd be working for
his own startup more likely
so regulating them i don't know if it's
right and also you know you put in
regulations
and then what happens is these companies
this is just human nature the companies
just like you would if someone gave you
a set of rules and you didn't like them
you'd figure out a way to skirt around
the rules right
so this is just human nature so i don't
think regulation works now
one of the things that trump did was he
he called out section 230 of the
communications act which
gave certain protections to these
companies right it gave certain legal
protections to these companies
and i think there was something by
scaling back some of their legal
protections perhaps it could encourage
them
to be more fair i think that's probably
the right idea here but let's not forget
uh what do i say 20 times a day the road
to hell is paid with good intentions so
i think trump's intentions here were
good let's
let's scale back some of their legal
protections so hopefully they will
self-regulate
the problem is now if they have to be
looking at the content
on their platforms you youtube google
twitter etc if they have to be looking
at it more critically because now
they're open to lawsuits well then they
might
they might actually be worse when it
comes to free speech
so you got to be careful about that so
then the third option is that you break
these companies
up and and this i think maybe there's
some version there
again this is not the purely libertarian
take but ultimately
well i consider myself a realist i don't
view the world as i want it to be i view
the world as it is
and if we are to have a government which
i think most of us agree we have to have
and those of us that are leery about
power usually would say well you don't
want
a big endlessly powerful government
but we also don't want companies that
can become immeasurably more powerful
than that government and i don't think
the founders could have ever envisioned
envisioned companies like google that
have
extraordinary really unmatched
unparalleled power over our lives the
information we get
the way we think about things the things
that they can make disappear the things
that they can put in
and again this is why i've been saying
over the last couple weeks we are in a
reality war
that is the war that we are in right now
you could say we're in a political war
you can say we're in a cultural war but
both of those
sit within the idea that we're in a
reality war people
are getting catered information to them
that is making them think one way
or making them think another way or
maybe making them think a third way
but then it's constantly be reinforced
by companies and algorithms that we
don't understand and then when you throw
in the toxicity of wokeness
you can see why we're in such a big
problem so the idea that google has so
much power over the way we think if we
can't think clearly then how can we
possibly
elect people to govern clearly so
i think there's something probably there
and by the way you know some of the
people that will be involved
in the in the hearings on this uh like
ted cruz who i've had on the show and
discussed this stuff it's like this
guy's a brilliant constitutional lawyer
and i think he will be able
to uh elicit these arguments correctly
and and hopefully keep all of these
things in mind
um i would say i fit probably firmly
within the the space that ted cruz is on
this where
you're sort of your your belief system
is more on the libertarian side but then
there's like this other thing out there
which is also i can't just let
powerful companies decide everything
about my life
um you know it's just not right it's
just it's just not right
and it's sort of that's where you got to
kind of grate your teeth and be like all
right the government maybe
does have to do something anyway i would
love to know what you guys think about
this because
you know my thoughts are evolving on it
as well and if you do want to
share your thoughts with me this is
exactly why we created the reuben report
community
so join us at reubenreport.com and we've
got thousands of people in there
commenting and sharing videos and you
can share memes and and everything else
and i have a much better chance of
seeing what you're going to say
uh because it's it's somewhat of a of a
gated environment
instead of the wild west that is the
twitter and youtube comment section
all right let's move on to the uh the
second story this is a really
this is really interesting out of the uk
so this conservative mp
conservative member of parliament from
safran
walden she's the treasury and equalities
minister she gave a really i would say
impactful speech
uh on the floor of the house of commons
yesterday and it went viral
so let's take a look what we are against
is the
teaching of contested political ideas
as if they are accepted facts we don't
do this with communism we don't do this
with socialism we don't do it with
capitalism
and i want to speak about a dangerous
trend in race relations that has come
far too close to home to my life
and this is the promotion of critical
race theory an ideology that sees my
blackness as victimhood
and their whiteness as oppression i want
to be absolutely clear this government
stands
unequivocally against critical race
theory
some schools have decided to openly
support the anti-capitalist black lives
matter group
often fully aware that they have a
statutory duty to be politically
impartial
black lives do matter of course they do
but we know
that black lives matter movement capital
b
l m is political i know this because at
the height of the protest i have been
told
of white black lives matter's protesters
calling and i'm afraid uh i apologize
for saying this word calling
a black aunt police officer guarding
downing street a pet
that is why we do not endorse that
movement in
on this side of the house it is a
political movement and what would be
nice would be for members on the
opposite side to condemn
many of the actions that we see this
political movement instead of pretending
that it is a completely wholesome
uh anti-racist organization there is a
lot of pernicious stuff that is being
pushed
and we stand against that we do not want
to see teachers
teaching their white pupils about white
privilege and inherited racial guilt
and let me be clear any school which
teaches these elements of critical race
theory as fact
or which promotes parties and political
views such as defunding the police
without offering a balanced treatment of
opposing views
is breaking the law ah
kemi i didn't know you until yesterday
but i love you
um okay there's a lot there i do want to
mention that you may have noticed we had
a little uh edit
a minor minor edit in there where we did
cut out
about 10 seconds and i want to be
totally transparent with you as to why
we did it
she did quote what a black lives matter
activist was calling
a black police officer and she used
language that if we were just to play
that clip
this clip this reuben report clip would
automatically be demonetized that sort
of
gets directly back to the first story we
talked about um
so we just cut out that 10 second
portion where she actually
said that word and that that's sort of a
whole other thing about policing and
language and big tech and everything
else
but there's a lot of good stuff that she
said in there and i want to i want to go
through a bunch of it what she said at
the beginning that that first part was
really brilliant she said what we are
against
is the teaching of contested
political ideas we don't do this with
communism etc now think about this what
we're against
is the teaching of contested political
ideas marxism
critical race theory identity politics
wokeness all of these things that i know
you guys know all about
these are contested political ideas
they're contested because in a free
society
you don't get to just say i'm right
everyone else is wrong and i will rule
over you
that being said the people who are
pushing these ideas
they want them to be
more powerful than every other set of
ideas including in the united states the
set of ideas that is our constitution
and our bill of rights
so they want these things taught
critical race theory they want it taught
at the expense
of teaching a truly liberal arts
education they want it to be
taught at the expense of teaching true
history right they
want the 1619 project which even now the
new york times is slowly
being forced to admit was in many ways a
work of fiction
they want that to be taught in history
classes
instead of teaching true american
history now
you can say okay but maybe we've made
some mistakes in teaching american
history i'm not even making that
argument but you could say it
but the idea and the key word we're
teaching
contested political ideas they're not
right just because they say they're
right so if you want to
teach traditional american history and
then make mention
there's this thing in the 1619 project
in the new york times called the 1619
project and it also has been criticized
and blah blah blah
well that would basically be okay but
what's happening is and this is what
she's getting to these things are
actually
illegal because they are seeping into
all of our institutions
now let's remember who's the guy
that took critical race theory out of
our federal institutions right so there
was
the whole idw crew and all of the
interesting youtubers and podcasters
that have broken out over the last
couple years we were all rallying
against identity politics
we were all railing against critical
race theory and
and railing against it and talking about
it is one thing and i often would say
you know a year or two ago you know what
do we do after we're done talking about
it after we've woken up enough of you
guys that are watching this
and people have gone from woke to awake
well what do you actually do
and and i don't know that we ever got a
good answer on it but the but the answer
is that you actually have to do
something about it and the irony
i think for the remaining sane liberals
the six or seven of them that are left
is well donald trump is the guy that saw
critical race theory being
leaked into our system and he said we
will not teach this at our federal
agencies and we won't even do
business with companies that are that is
that is an extraordinarily powerful
move you may not like donald trump but
he did it and you got to give
credit where credit is due these things
not only should be not being taught in
our schools or at least should be taught
with a counterpoint
showing that they're contested political
ideas
right capitalism is a i believe it's the
best uh
economic system for us to be free but
it's a contested political idea so you
can teach capitalism the same way you
could teach communism and hopefully
you'd go into the history and go you
know boy it's something else
every capitalist country actually
succeeds and thrives and is generally
peaceful
uh and it ain't the same with the with
the communists and the socialists
so trump is the one that did this this
is very much in line with the idea
of what trump did with title ix we had
title ix that was put in by the
obama administration where in effect
they took the right to due process
away from college students so if you
were accused
of sexual harassment the school could in
effect just suspend you
or get rid of you or decide what to do
with you without it going through the
proper legal channels that was an obama
administration
uh executive action that trump got out
of the schools
he did these things are not disconnected
so it's just important to know about
this stuff
a couple other lines that she said there
um she made a point specifically of
saying that black lives matter is a
political movement
and i think it's very important for you
guys when you get into these debates
with your friends
that that's the line as she said we all
believe black lives matter i want black
people to be treated absolutely equally
under the law the same way i want
white people and christian people to be
that's just
and by the way that's how most of us
think the wide majority of us think and
that's pretty much how it is in the
united states and
by the way it's pretty much how it is in
the uk as well
but this is a political movement black
lives matter
is a political movement trying to
destroy our institutions and replace
them
with what i obviously think are bad
ideas uh
and then and then finally she also said
this thing about the balance of opposing
views
and of course that that's that's in line
with this idea of the contested views
that
we want we want to teach people how to
think
uh instead of instead of critical race
theory we need critical thinking how
about that let's do some critical
thinking
all right and speaking of critical
thinking i'm now going to show you
someone who knows nothing about it
keith olbermann people he is the former
espn anchor former msnbc anchor former
current tv anchor
current youtube guy i suppose and let's
just show
a little bit of a little bit of his rant
about president trump
yesterday we are all tired
but mostly i'm tired of the needless
sickness and the needless death
and the needless terror because this
mentally incompetent
inhuman dumb bastard has lied about this
disease
in a thousand different ways a different
way for each different political need he
has
sensed and i'm tired of the thought that
we are now going to repeat the months of
march and april in this country a
country that should have learned
something but which in large part has
been authorized to wallow
and die in its own stupidity because of
one man
one dumb bastard one selfish son of a
[ __ ]
one real-life major french attacking the
only hope we have
the science and insisting science is
wrong and fauci is an idiot
and only i can save you and insisting
you can do whatever you want then the
disease affects almost nobody
donald trump should be on trial for 220
000 murders death penalty for each count
okay everything that's wrong about
television and news and current events
and media and social media and all
it's right there it's summed up you only
need two words to
to define it right those two words are
keith olbermann i mean it's it's the
horrific language
the call to murder somebody i mean the
guy
the guy is just a lunatic but what i
thought we'd do here is we took the
exact
transcript that he has there and also
the fake emotions right it's all
fake that's the thing he's an actor i'm
not acting here the camera's on so i'm
five percent more of what i would be if
i was sitting in my room alone
i suppose right there's some element of
i'm performing i suppose at some level
but this is just me talking
um but he's acting it's all an act so
what we did here is we took his
transcript
and now i am going to to include joe
biden we're going to say this is about
joe biden for your purposes if you want
to do it about barack obama or whoever
else but i'm going to try to read with
with the anger and emotion that this guy
just read i'm going to try to be as
morally outraged as he was with the
exact same language it's going to be
very difficult for me
but i did take an acting class about 20
years ago for about three weeks
known fact uh melissa rauch who played
bernadette on big bang theory was was in
my acting class
okay here we go we're all tired but
mostly i'm
tired of the endless sickness and the
needless death
and the needless terror because this
mentally incompetent
human dumb bastard has lied about this
disease a thousand different ways
and for a thousand different political
needs he has sensed and i'm tired
of the thought that we're now going to
repeat
months of march and april in this
country a country that should have
learned
something which in large part has been
authorized
to swallow i think it says there and die
in his own stupidity because
one man one dumb bastard
one selfish son of a [ __ ] one real
little little major french attacking the
only
hope we have of the science and
insisting
science is wrong and fouchy is an idiot
and only i can save you
and insisting you can do whatever you
want when the disease affects
almost nobody joe biden should be on
trial
for the 220 000 murders
death penalty for each count
that was the reuben report direct
message for today
october 21st 2020 enjoy
the rest of your day